hello this is dog walker and I bet
you're wondering what the hell am i
doing doing a commentary on this video
well I have a very very good reason
first of all I should explain that one
of the reasons you've seen this
commentary is you might have heard I got
a virus that took a long time to get rid
of it's a real nasty one there are some
issues with the website and stuff like
that but I also have Disney cember so
all these things were setting me back
and I apologize I've had a chance to do
you know sort of the usual ask that guys
and bum reviews and so forth but you're
still getting a nostalgia critics and
it's Disney December so just explain
that all right Oh what the hell my doing
talking about this well as many of you
probably know this video was not it was
not a big hit and a lot of people really
really disliked it and I think it's very
important to talk about what to do how
to handle a failure just as well as how
to handle a success because you can have
a ton of successes and great people love
you for it but once you have a failure
you have to know how to handle it
because if you keep getting successes
you're fine but once you have a failure
and you don't handle it well and you
handle it very poorly you can lose an
audience forever potentially and it'd be
very very hard to get them back if ever
so I think it's very important to talk
about that and this video uh I was not
satisfied with when I was done shooting
it I was really just sort of hoping and
praying that maybe you know that there's
just something there that maybe I'm not
seeing that maybe people like in anyway
because there are times where I've put
out videos that I felt you know wasn't
my stronger so it wasn't as good as it
could be but people still enjoy them so
you always sort of take that risk and
you probably hear over and over there's
so many times where a producer or
comedian performer whatever won't know
what's gonna be hit or not sometimes a
lot of things we think are gonna be
phenomenal
turn out to be big bombs a lot of things
we think are going to be big bombs turn
out to be big hits so when the reason
this did not turn out so well the
originally when I wanted to do this I
want do this like actually the first
like year I started doing nostalgia
critic as I saw these Let's Plays and I
surf it will that be this dr. Craig
doing a let's play that sort of be fun
and I actually did it very shortly after
like one of the first four or five
videos I did and I did a let's play but
the software the the camera the audio
didn't record for whatever reason so oh
and I did the whole thing live did all
the way through and I had to scream and
yell and stuff like that so all right so
just say I gotta do it all over again my
voices can soar but I'll try it again
and I did again at that point the video
recording software it didn't work it
glitched out on me and I finally just
said okay
I'm done I get my voice is gone and blah
blah blah I'll do it another time and I
was always sort of the idea is that if I
ever got too busy with stuff or I had
too many trips or something that this
could be sort of a fast easy video I
could do that could also be entertaining
when I was half right I was fast and
easy but it wasn't very entertaining um
and I think part of that is that you
know when I first tried recording this
and they didn't work I mean that was
about four or five years ago and I think
something you have to keep in mind when
you have an idea that you're really
proud of but you take a very very very
long time to get to it you have to keep
aware whether or not it's still fresh
it's still new and if it still works
because chances are a lot of other
people are gonna get to it and now I
don't think I wants to let's play at
Bart's nightmare but certainly serve a
lot of this yelling and getting angry
and stuff like that I mean these have
been seen in a lot of Let's Plays and
when I was first starting it off it
wasn't as common when I first tried to
record it and I didn't update I didn't
keep track of enough Let's Plays to see
that this happens all the time this is
sort of just really old news and not as
funny it's just sort of been done to
death on top of that there's not really
much detail to it to make it very you
know fascinating let's play as well
and something I think a lot of people
sort of misinterpreted which I do wanna
make very clear is that
when I was making the joke in the
opening day oh let's players do is if
that's even the term all these people do
Let's Plays do is they just play a game
and talk to me well that's easy I can do
that blah blah blah the idea behind that
was to show that it was not easy and I
get very frustrated I can't make it all
the way through uh it was not to say
let's players have no talent there's
nothing to it it that was the joke is
that the Nostalgia Critic doesn't know
any better any a Zamora he doesn't know
he's getting himself into
and I chose Bart's nightmare because
there's just it's actually not that
horrible a game it can get very
difficult at times but I chose him more
because there's so many various levels
that you can do and when you do lose
it's very humorous and there's so many
various ways that you can die and you
can lose and you can mess up rules and
such so I thought it'd be a good choice
but again as let's play it's not a
horrible game really and that's another
thing that really worked against me
forever worked for me it's supposed to
work against me but it was actually too
helpful so when I did this I did this
one I had Oh was it yeah I think at the
New York trip coming up
I had the Austria trip I just went on a
vacation as well and I had a con I mean
so all these things were going on and
you don't know I took a bag the New York
trip wasn't in there but it was a con it
was a vacation and it was the Austria
trip I mean that's about two to three
weeks of being preoccupied and you have
to just you know I'm a sucker for
deadlines I really I don't like missing
deadlines I like to get things out I
don't like you know people being
disappointed or not giving a video so I
really really try hard to squeeze things
down this is a time where it actually
really really worked against me because
a lot of times when I put out videos and
they've been rushed it's still like well
it's still in establish a Craig video in
people you know can respect that and
still like it but with this this is when
this is the time it really backfired and
I know there's a lot of people come to
me and cons instead of saying I like the
let's play I don't know what what the
problem is that's great thank you for
the support I don't like it I and I
think that really sort of the thing
about it is that
when I put it out there I was saying I
don't think this is good I don't know if
this is gonna work but let me try it you
know it's still a risk you know but
that's that's the business of thinking
races a lot of times they don't work and
it's even harder when you think it's not
gonna work and then it turns out it
doesn't but you did anyway and that's
that's the worst cuz you have nobody but
yourself to blame and those are the
toughest wants to deal with because if I
felt no this is a good video this is
this really works I don't know why so
many people are against it no I know
exactly why they're against I know
exactly why they didn't enjoy it um so I
do understand that and now but the
interesting thing with that is that the
next video actor was James in the Giant
Peach and I just got back from the trip
from Austria and I just heard how this
video was doing it just people were
hating it really hating it and here's
the thing with negative comments or of
course it is constructive criticism you
anyone in this business you know can and
should take that if it's just people
saying you know this is horrible the
worst thing or you're worse than cancer
or whatever the you know whatever they
want to say usually doesn't affect you
and you have to know going in you're
gonna get a lot of you're gonna get
people yelling it use it and so on so
forth um the only time for me and I find
out with a lot of producers some
producers can get really affected by it
most of us I find we don't really get
that effect unless we're in a bad mood
and if we hear those comments on top of
the fact that we're just sort of bummed
out or things imma going our way or
whatever that's when it'll really sort
of piss us off and get to us I met for
some reason I wasn't a bad mood maybe it
was because it was being taken so badly
I haven't had video been taking this
badly for a while but I was just sort of
in a bad mood and I think I just came
from Austria too so I think I had like
the jetlag as well and I was just sort
of semi discombobulated um and I had the
idea and I just I want to do something
I'm really sort of like stuck it to the
fans I was just saying don't key I mean
for crying out loud they're getting this
err attainment for free up I'm working
real hard here and blah blah blah
I'll show them up put together really
clever video so I start off with the
James and the Giant Peach
video and the opening was pretty much
the same where I have this press
conference saying pretty much an apology
and I'm coming out of like the prison of
bad video gamers or something like that
and when when I made it up to the point
where the bum comes in it's the same but
then actually it's not the bum that
originally was in there originally
I shot douchey mid nitpick and he was
coming up in he was you know what it's
like to point you for hours and hours
talking about how much I don't like you
well then why do you want your flowers
an hour and I did this video and I show
it to rob or just yeah that'll kill
without sticking or blah blah blah and
we watched it and Rob through a
masterful you know thought process said
shot to Mike for its Mike Machado the
CEO is it cuz I I think it's funny but I
we should be safe here we should really
be safe and I said okay alright if I'm
sure we'll be fine
Mike looks it over and pretty much says
I mean the great thing about Mike is I
he'll never say I mean almost never say
no don't run it absolutely not are you
crazy blah blah blah he says you know I
very strongly suggest you don't he says
because honestly I don't think we can
get away with this argument anymore that
it's it's free entertainment that you
know we're trying hard that we're just
sort of these you know we're just serve
people having fun why won't you just
have fun with us as I know we've really
have to be taking this seriously and we
had to be taking the fans seriously and
he was absolutely 100% right about it
and the other thing that I really
realized about it that you know just
totally didn't make it work is the fact
that I didn't like the video either so
why am i blaming my fans for liking a
video that even I didn't enjoy they have
every right not to enjoy it um I guess I
was just sort of taken aback and I'm
always sort of again this is something
you just have to get used to that there
are
that's gonna be people that take this
stuff so seriously and just will not let
up on it and will just I need just
really really obsess over it and it's
it's hard to understand do you know
because you just say are I learn more
important things is this really hurting
you
really this is this is really getting
you upset
so you just sorta have to put up with it
and just be like you know what these are
still your fans these are still people
that you know if not for them you
wouldn't be doing the job that you
absolutely love so I went back and I
recorded this opening where again the
first half is the same but then the bum
comes up and says you have to repay your
debt you have to you know change there
another one my thing you have to
actually talk about you know something
bad people why do you review but you
never could and that's how we lean to
James and the Giant Peach which it turns
out was perfect cuz I did find out a lot
of people did enjoy that that was
another one where Louis serve sends me
an email just like you know you don't
read carefully on that a lot of people
really like that movie and blah blah
blah so it actually came perfect right
after doing this because then I have to
be nice to the movie and and you can get
some good jokes out of that uh so I
think it's very very important to know
how to handle a bomb and I should say a
failure because I'm either there's gonna
be people are gonna like this I mean fit
Philly's a pretty strong word but a bomb
which is not a much nicer word but it's
something that did not you know please
the majority of people and that that
really is what a bomb is I mean there's
always gonna be one or two people
that'll like something that you know it
really doesn't do well but you know the
majority did not like it and I think
probably reason so many of them got
upset like early upset is because they
thought I wasn't taking it seriously and
I I was trying but there is true that I
did not have the amount of time to do
the research on Let's Plays again and
really see how far it's come
and every once while I try to watch one
but I mean as people sort of know I'm
not really a
I know these games I know sir the Super
Nintendo and the Nintendo you know and a
few we games or game games but not many
and I thought that again I thought that
let's our work to my advantage you know
doing bad on a game and it's your reason
a lot of time any time it did something
video game related people really liked
in the guy on board for it and you know
I think they're okay but I never got
that into him like the babies kids won I
mean people loved that one it's cute but
I mean people really really get behind
that one l of reviews I think are just
okay like people you know really really
really adore like a baby a robber review
honestly I think is only okay and that's
like almost everybody's favorite I mean
they just love it um so you never know
and it's I think what I really drew out
it is that I knew but I think I forgot
for a bit is that you cannot insult your
fans you have to you can have fun with
him you can play with him you can do
satires and make jokes and stuff you can
never directly insult them and honestly
you shouldn't because again these are
the people that are keeping you doing
what you love if I mean I'm care you
have the best manager in the world or
whatever I mean unless you have a ton of
people watching you you're not going to
be able to do this and you really owe
them so much and to come out insulting
them especially for a video that you
yourself don't like that's not the right
move that's not the right thing to do
and so I think it's always good to you
have to sort of you have to be able to
make fun of yourself and everybody knows
I do that a lot I love doing that I
think that's a yeah it's tremendous fun
to do um but you can't do it too much
either you have to do it at just the
right amount and that's hard to figure
out because if you do it too much it
sort of looks like you're too hard on
yourself you're being too mean and it
starts to become awkward for the viewer
and you can't go too far with that
either you have to find just the right
amount unfortunately that takes a lot of
trial and error
um so yeah I don't think I got this is a
long video um so yeah I think like I
said I think it's very very important to
know how stupid I mean get that smaller
um I think it's very important to know
just how to handle a failure because if
you ever gonna go into anything you know
it's gonna say anything entertainment
wise but no really anything you're
always gonna fail at something you're
never gonna get everything right and the
best thing to do always is just to learn
from it you can't let it you know
destroy you you can't let it you know
tear you apart okay you're gonna have
failures no matter what the point where
you really get concerned is if you're
having too many failures if you're
getting them in a row and that's when
you really have to be concerned about
what you're doing you have to really
start changing things up like I do
remember there's a point in my reviews
where I could actually feel like I was
getting too repetitive and I wasn't
keeping in new and fresh anymore and I
had to do something about I remember the
exact reviews it was it was why it was
the pound puppies movie and the pebble
on the penguin those two I I reviewed
them and I did the reviews how they met
so this is gonna be something this is
gonna be just like all the Ernest Alger
cards I've done you know good you know
and I think at a point some people were
saying like you know these gets
repetitive I don't know and I would say
oh I'll show them by doing the exact
same thing I always do and that's not
what you want out so trying to go back
and find the roots of the nostalgia
Creek and that actually was not the
problem I was doing that too much I was
playing something reacting to it and or
and or playing a movie clip and that was
very similar to it and I was just
stating the obvious in these reviews in
those to review specifically I recall
thinking to myself this is gonna be
great and it was just like all the other
reviews and that's finally when I said
okay I can't do this anymore I have to
I'm gonna lose my audience if I just
keep doing this over and over I have to
really spend more time on these jokes
and I have to really really serve up the
game because I think people are gonna
show it and people aren't as you know I
think after a while you sort of thing
well they love me because I'm doing what
I'm always doing but you had to ask
yourself would you love something they
kept doing what it just always kept
doing and never added anything new or
fresh so I started to really spend more
time on the writing and honestly I think
this year in 2011 that you turned out to
be one of the better years for the
nostalgia critic because I think we have
tried so many new things and French
things I spent much more time on the
writing than I used to because after a
while I was sort of trained to just sort
of a Mystery Science Theater Mystery
Science Theater slash me just looking
puzzled at something slash play a movie
clip and you can't do that you have to
get more creative jokes you have to do
sketches you have to find new ways of
looking at something you have to they
can't all be Alpers a lot of them you
have to really downplay or you have to
you know you can't hate every single
movie you see you have to maybe sort of
like it or find something to enjoy so
keeping it really fresh you know just
turning it up a bit is important and
that's sort of what I was hoping with
this I was hoping that this would be
something where I try it and is just
here's something new because anytime you
do something new it is a risk because
almost always you're gonna find people
who are not gonna like it and you know
that's fine and maybe even split down
the line or down the road people
sometimes open up to it and the most
verbal sadly are the ones that hate
something are negative about it a good
example of that actually is the the
stuff with the video game nerd when I
was doing the fights and then the the
final battle and the brawl and stuff
like that uh you know at first people
love it what it's some people actually
thought was serious for a moment uh you
know they got really angry how dare are
you calling this but I think a lot of
the people after a while worsen yeah I
think I'm done with this I don't want
these go anywhere come on boy you guys
gonna have a big fight of blah blah blah
and those comments were sort of adding
up to but I sort of felt no I think we
have something really funny here and I
think we should continue forward with it
and it's like I guess the majority was
positive but there were there was like a
good one
that was just like no I don't like this
no this stop no more you know did you
just knock it off um and again that's
one of the most popular things I've ever
done was just the the fights with the
video game nerd and I think sometimes
you know what when time goes by you know
it shows I mean there are times where
people won't like something because
they're watching it from a certain point
of view they're watching it for a first
time which sometimes can be great but
other times you have to see everything
back-to-back and I think the nerd battle
is a great example of that where when
you watch it all together it's really
funny it's really enjoyable but if
you've been waiting and waiting you know
for for something to come of this and
then you see what it is it's not exactly
what you expected sometimes the build-up
can backfire but with a you know again
with Batman Robin when that first came
out I mean that sort of God you know
yeah you know if it was hooray about it
but I think they liked it okay
but again that's like one of the most
memorable people who loved to quote it
people love to you know watch it over
and over it's one of the most viewed so
it just sort of varies and you're never
gonna know for sure so anytime you take
a risk with something new you have to
make sure it's a calculated risk and I
think that was the problem with this it
was not a calculated risk it was trying
something new but it didn't prepare
properly for it the right way to have
done it is either a done it when I first
want to do it I mean just sort of drink
a lot of water and don't care if my
voice got sore and just do the Let's
Plays when it was when it was still sort
of a new thing and that or if I'm gonna
do it again really do my research really
look into it see how Let's Plays are
being done and do it from there
because I think that's one of the main
process that this was just - this was
far too late and the jokes were just way
away too old I think sometimes you see
directors that sort of do that - I
thought it was that a great example of
people like George Lucas or Martin
Scorsese with you know the Star Wars
prequels or well is that DiCaprio
Scorsese movie that he wanted to do for
years and years I was actually very
ah forget him the gaze of New York now
is it and when that came out people were
just are like really this was the movie
you want to do for like 15 20 years and
stuff like that and but honestly it
shows because it wasn't that updated all
the stuff had sort of already been done
before and you could even sort of make
the argument with Lucas and Star Wars
that you know and I don't know if the
stuffs already been done but he wasn't
sort of keeping track of what people
were looking for and what they wanted
and how they view the trilogy and maybe
he didn't want to maybe it's just like
no you know what I have the story I want
to tell it and he made it good friend um
but you know I don't think he can be too
shocked when people don't enjoy it or or
really ban it I guess even he makes
jokes about apparently every time to see
him on interview he seems like a cool
guy actually I feel that they have
making fun of him so much but he seems
really cool and it seems very smart but
I digress
um like I said the whole point this was
to show you know sort of the best way to
handle something that doesn't succeed
because actually I think that's just as
important if not more important than
handling something that's a success and
you always have to be ready for people
that are going to not like your work and
they're gonna you know make fun of it of
really uh you know or get emotional
about it that's always the weirdest
thing that's the hardest thing to get
used to is when people just take it so
emotionally and and don't get me wrong I
take my work seriously I really do and I
work very hard at it and it takes up so
much time but it's always so fascinating
to see these people there you know I do
I see it's just it's just a game it's
just a review it's just a guy yelling at
a camera and I feel sir the same way
with uh you know people get angry at you
know whatever it says some of these
youtubers are like pop stars or or any
of that you know like Justin Bieber you
know or someone like Glenn Beck or
something like that have you heard what
he said today have you don't watch him
there you know no I want to watch him so
I can get even more angry at what he's
saying
said why are you viewing it you know
they're they're obviously gonna find
their crowd I you know I think the only
point where I sort of cracked recently
about that it I really don't I think the
only time we raced I got really pissed
off as that new Twilight Breaking Dawn
and that's really
but even then I mean it is or true it's
like you know what it's just we as a
society we sort we get whatever we
deserve because we we feed it you know
and we watch it and if you don't great
what is not talking about it you know if
you're really concerned about this with
other people have conversations with
them I mean don't and don't force your
point of view just sort of say what you
think of it just offer it don't shove it
in their faces don't don't force it and
I think again that's where what I was
trying to do with the original video
that was gonna go up talking about this
and you just can't you can 40 you can
shove it
the Nostalgia Critic can because it's a
character and I think people do often
sometimes confuse that it's supposed to
be me it's not it is a character there's
a lot of me in it and a lot of my
opinions are in there but in terms of
you must hate this because I hate it
that's not true you know that's an a
when it says that don't believe them
it's your opinion enjoy it if you hate
something I do go ahead and ate it so
that's probably the only really good
part of the video that's the only part I
liked so guys thank you for watching I
apologize for this video for those I
liked it continue to like it for those
that don't continue to don't continue to
not excuse me thank you and take care